[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to spectator tvs the week in 60
minutes
the third in our series the first two
both had well over a hundred thousand
viewers each
and if you miss them it's not too late
to catch up on the spectator's youtube
channel
we have another jam-packed show for you
today but before i run through our
guests
a quick reminder that if you enjoy what
we're doing then
take up a subscription offer to the
magazine
we're europe's fastest growing politics
and current affairs publication and you
can try a month
absolutely free that'll give you full
online access to all of our articles
podcasts and newsletters as well as
instant delivery of the magazine
via the spectator app each week if you
like it
you'll pay just 9.99 pounds a month
thereafter
to take up this offer click the i button
in the top right hand corner
of this youtube video or go to spectator
dot co dot uk
forward slash tv over this week we have
another jam pack show for you kicking
off
will be anders tegnal he's the
epidemiologist behind sweden's
controversial covert strategy
i'll be asking him whether sweden has
got it right i've also talked to the
spectators political team
on boris johnson's track record so far
such as it is has he been missing in
action
finally as israel signs a peace accord
with bahrain and the united arab
emirates
this week brokered by president trump
we'll be talking about whether or not mr
trump's form policy has been
underestimated and of course we'll then
hear from you
so please send your questions through
via the q a
chat in zoom and it's thanks again to
the natwest group for their support for
this program
they back the first two episodes they've
kept the faith with us for this week
natwest group is the biggest supporter
of businesses across the uk
and is working hard during the pandemic
to help businesses and personal
customers
get through this difficult period now
brexit hit the headlines again but
covered is never far from them
is britain are facing a second wave of
covet
the rule of six was introduced this week
and the papers are full of speculation
of what might be next such as curfews
the logic is simple there are surge in
detected infections is underway
in france and spain and unless it's
suppressed this will be followed by a
surge in hospital numbers and deaths
so the examples of our european
neighbors are being used as the basis
for a new crackdown in britain which you
might think
is fair enough but is it but every
country is witnessing a surge in
infections in june
sweden the country with probably the
most controversial covert strategy of
not logging down started to see a second
surge in cases
but it didn't take off only 1.2 percent
of tests performed in the country
last week came back positive lower
lower infection levels than either
denmark or norway now to brit sweden
looks like a country from a parallel
universe its children under
16 didn't miss a day of school its
government even banked
a surplus in august but the virus has
hit it hard
like all the others per capita so why is
sweden a position to move from
gatherings of 50 to perhaps 500 which is
now on the agenda in stockholm
while britain is bracing itself for a
second wave how confident can we be that
sweden is in the clear
well the architect of sweden's covet
policy anders tegno
joins us live from sweden he's on a
train
so we just hope uh swedish 4g is as good
as it's cracked up to be
anders can you hear me i can hear you
excellent anders let's hope it stays
that way i want to look at what's
happening in sweden now
but before i do i want to step back and
look with what has happened
since the outbreak of covert now sweden
has had to date
579 covert related deaths
per million that's not far off britain's
613
deaths per million now nobody thinks
britain
is a success story in its handling of
covet
so why should sweden be regarded as a
success story
yeah i mean that's a good question maybe
because
we are now in a fairly stable situation
with a very low number of
the number of cases in sweden uh we are
lower than most other european countries
did stage and its
steam a
fairly stable test stage sweden's also
fared much worse than its scandinavian
neighbors and they
had lockdowns i mean deaths per million
in norway
have been a tenth of in denmark
they're only a fifth of swedens and they
had lockdowns
yes but i think we also need to realize
that the epidemic has been
very different in sweden than in in the
other than atlanta belgium with a vast
number in the very beginning which was
very difficult to handle
while the numbers in both norway and
finland has all the time with much lower
and much easier to handle
so what would have happened if denmark
or norway did not have a lockdown is
still a question that's open
it is true and i've seen you say this
that many of sweden's early fatalities
happened in care homes and it seems like
there was a scandal in your care homes
as there was in
britain and in france and in other
countries
too but even if you take out the
fatalities
in care homes norway and sweden sorry
norway and denmark
still had fewer fatalities per capita
than sweden many of you
yes that's true and i think we're still
striving to completely understand that
because we also need
to understand that the south of sweden a
region with a couple of million
inhabitants
had much lower death rates than
copenhagen
so these differences are not universal
in sweden these are differences mainly
between stockholm
and other the other countries other
parts of sweden especially the south
which is just as densely populated as
denmark or norway and their death rate
and the general amount of cases they had
were very much lower with the same
policy that we used in all over sweden
so i think we're gonna have to wait for
quite some time to understand which
measures worked and which did not
were the swedish authorities culpable
in allowing so many deaths to happen in
the caring homes
no because this was so questionable
allowing
there was no way we could have foreseen
this and it was definitely not
a policy to allow it to happen uh we had
unfortunately the weaknesses you know in
not all but
a number of our old homes facilities
those weaknesses have now been rectified
and we don't see any
spread in the old figures old folks from
home anymore and we don't see any
deaths in those places either so
we all wish that those rectifying
measures could have been done early on
but
this did unfortunately not happen let me
come
to now because something is happening in
sweden and it seems to be different from
what
we've experienced in spain or france or
now even the united kingdom
i mean in britain they're now worrying
about a second wave
coming but that doesn't seem to be a
worry in sweden i see that new
swedish cases are now 90 percent below
the late june peak
and you're now actually in new cases
below norway and denmark for the first
time
what's happening anders yeah
which i think a couple of things are
happening we have kept the same kind of
measures in place all the time
and they now seem to take a great effect
we have not opened up society like they
have done in denmark in norway and i
think that makes a difference
it is also probably so that we have a
certain
immunity in the population and that
helps us but
most of all i think we have had the same
policies in place
we have a high level of compliance with
the population to follow those measures
even if they're vulnerable
and i think now that really pays off let
me come back to the
home team and ask uh a phrase of this
president
you've followed what's happened in
sweden very carefully you speak swedish
you
are married to a swede which of course
is a necessary
precondition of getting on in the
spectator these days uh
let me ask you this uh are we now
beginning to see
the absence of a lockdown in sweden
paying dividends
well that's certainly what's um part of
the original argument was there was no
point in locking down because as soon as
you release
lockdown then you will simply get a
delayed version of what you were trying
to
avoid in the first place there are also
um
under technical referred to a certain
immunity now that is quite interesting
uh there are
it's interesting discussion as to
whether the susceptible people
um in sweden who are probably right on
the verge of the most likely to get it
or succumbs sadly to this earlier on and
that the virus has been
since april finding it harder and harder
to find people
who were susceptible um in an interview
this morning to dagens theater and
understandable also mentioned that
sweden has got this um
there are few people who died of flu in
the last winter and as a result of that
there were more people
um who were surviving but on the edge of
um on the very edge of health
and that might have been a factor so the
other thing that sweden says it's too
early to tell there are great ones for
saying
look wait a year wait two years wait
three years before we can
work things out but there certainly is a
feeling
there's no talk of a second wave in
sweden here we are in britain locking
down
i think one in seven people in the
country now is in some form of lockdown
swedes don't expect that and when andros
tagonella has asked
do you expect a second wave he basically
doesn't and that's very interesting
because there isn't a swedish version
of this virus there's only one
coronavirus
so the big question is what if it's true
for sweden could it be true for britain
as well because both of us sweden and
britain
were hit very hard early on our journeys
are more similar than you might think
it was interesting that when the the
neil ferguson and
the uh number crunchers at imperial
in london where the british government
panicked
when his projections forecast hundreds
of thousands of deaths
unless action was taken including a
lockdown
i see that they also did a model for
sweden and uh
some of the number crunching there
suggested that there would be 85 000
deaths in sweden
with no lockdown uh but the swedes
ignored that
and decided to not to do a lockdown
the johnson government panicked and did
a lockdown
it's hard to say given that the actual
outcome in sweden
is under 6 000 deaths not 85 000
maybe the swedish government did the
right thing by not panicking
well that's the funny thing i mean
anders technical is a trained
epidemiologist he's got experience in
the field he's been
in africa he's dealt with ebola and
the uh was actually quite a lot of
expertise in sweden in the field of
epidemiology and the expertise
led them to be very skeptical about desk
based
projections and and when the imperial
college figures came out
and sweden decided still not to lock
down that was an incredibly
dramatic moment in sweden because a
great many people were thinking well if
you're wrong
we could have a quarter of a million
people in intensive care 85 000
dead there was an academic at lund
university who translated
imperial college's numbers and said this
is exactly what's going to happen
as it turned out that was overstated by
a factor of 13.
that was the big gamble that anders
tegenel took and it looks as if he's
back on the line now so he might be able
to tell us
a bit more about what went through his
mind at that moment
all right anderson we got you back again
can you hear me
yeah i can hear you sorry about that
break oh don't worry
these are the difficulties that are set
to try us
is it are we right to see that
there's a fear of a second wave now in
spain and france and britain and other
places
but there doesn't seem to be a fear of a
second wave in
sweden is that correct
yeah i think and and mainly because we
see that the second wave to
to a great extent depends on that these
countries now open up their society
after a severe lockdown
we are not in that situation we have
seen a falling trend
all since april basically now
dramatically falling during the summer
with the same kind of measures in place
and that's why we we are reasonably
confident you can never be confident
with this
virus but we're reasonably confident
that we're not going back to the same
situation we had this spring
because the measures are in place some
immunity are in place
and we have a lot better preparedness
when it comes to testing and healthcare
and other things
in place now than we had this spring
let's move back on to domestic
affairs and to the position of boris
johnson's government
maybe the government here in britain
should be paying more attention to the
swedish experience
but instead of loosening up we seem to
be heading into a second bout of
restrictions with little
to no transparency over what's leading
the government
to make its decisions are seven people
really more infectious than
six why is grouse shooting safer than a
birthday party
why can't seven children feed the ducks
but seven adults can shoot them because
that would seem to be
the british government's rules at the
moment none of this adds up to what
we've heard about
the prime minister mr johnson he's meant
to be the great
communicator something of a libertarian
brewing communicator we're told
so why isn't he leading from the front
president nelson asked the questions of
the former
spectator editor in this week's cover
piece prison talk us through what you
were saying
well right now there is a common
conversation that you tend to have when
you talk to conservative mps and that is
a complaint not simply about the debacle
of of the couple that last couple of
weeks with a withdrawal bill
but there was exams fiasco and the way
that this government now seems to be
being defined
by its mistakes what seems to be lacking
they say is leadership
and direction now the strange thing is
that that was exactly why boris johnson
was elected
leader people thought he would be able
to to lift spirits through dark times to
be able to point to the reason why we
are leaving the european union rather
than let it get bogged down as theresa
may did
in this kind of endless discussion about
parliamentary
obstacles and there's a growing sense of
frustration and just disbelief
that a man who they know to be a very
good communicator
previously these skills seem to have
left him now
and that's he seems to be you know he's
in the commons um
getting given lectures incompetence by
ed miliband
or talking to the liaison committee
yesterday about
contradicting some of his earlier
advices ministers gave about the
northern ireland it all seems to just be
going
wrong and the question is what has
happened
where is the leader they thought they
were getting
now this is not a mutiny nobody's saying
it's time for michael gove nobody's
saying that
jeremy hunt should be there instead
there's just a feeling that something is
dysfunctional something is going very
wrong
in the boris johnson operation about
just walking into unforced error after
unforced error but northern ireland
and the concept that the last two weeks
have been very easily avoided
whoever it was decided to come out with
the idea
that you announced you would break
international law
obviously didn't think about the effect
this would have on the party
the rebellion on the country because it
makes you wonder
what is the worth of a tory promise if
they're so willing to renege on those
promises
and also internationally we read
backlashes from
american politicians saying we can
forget about our trade deal
if this is how we treat our treaties
boris johnson is supposed to have a deft
political touch
and a lot of mps are saying this simply
hasn't been evidence now for a very very
long time
james the the political danger here is
obvious but i i think it may be also be
exacerbated by
whereas mr johnson and his government
could get away with lots of mistakes in
the early days people cut them some
slack they were
trying to find things up as they went
along it's now september
and we're meant to be coming out of this
pandemic and yet the government still
seems
to be all over the place i would suggest
the the
british public will now be inclined to
cut them a lot less slack
yes i mean this is why politically any
second wave
of the virus is going to be much more
difficult for the government than the
first wave
of even though this country is now
better prepared
there's a hugo poll out today saying
that public confidence in the
government's handling of a crisis is the
lowest it's been since it started
and i think if you look at this row over
testing and actually sums up the problem
the uk is doing vastly more testing than
it was
back during the first wave but people
are getting
angry and angrier that they can't get
tests that
the capacity has not kept up with demand
that the government didn't see this
spike
in the demand for tests coming when
schools and universities went back in
september
which seems odd and i think the danger
for the government
is the government's always most
vulnerable when a policy issue directly
affects voters lives
and this difficulty in getting tests is
directly affecting people's lives
and i think that is going to push
further back of the government's
reputation for competence
and i think one of the things that is
keeping a lid on the situation in
westminster
is the fact that the tories have a lead
in the polls i mean if you see
if this testing fiasco carries on
and that hancock is talking about it
being fixed in a matter of weeks which
doesn't give you confidence that there's
going to be any
any imminent solution then i think you
could see those numbers begin to change
and then i think the mood at westminster
could become uh
more rancorous katie is fraser an
outlier here
in these criticisms uh
or can you begin to detect on the tory
back benches
some of these sentiments bubbling up no
i don't think fraser is an outlier and
actually
uh i've been surprised by the number of
mps members of government i've had
message today
saying that they agree with lots of
what's in fraser's piece you've seen a
few people
uh you know on twitter take go go to
social media to defend the prime
minister
but privately i've had people say to me
today actually
this reflects a lot of people's concerns
and this is because
these people who are ultimately
supportive of boris johnson
they want his premiership to do well
it's not
those people who feel as though they are
pushed aside i think what should worry
number 10
is the people who are beginning to
express privately at least
concerns about how things are going are
actually people who backed boris johnson
and so this is you know revenge of the
remainers and i think there is an issue
and it goes to what james
is saying which is there is a sense not
just amongst the public but amongst the
parliamentary party that the government
has had
time now over the summer to come up with
a better strategy on coronavirus
now there's more than just coronavirus
annoying people but i do think on
coronavirus things like when the prime
minister
and matt hancock talk about operation
moonshot
it actually riles a lot of tory mps
because they think this idea of millions
of tests daily
is just in a way almost insulting when
the government can't even really do
a couple of hundred thousand a day well
can you if
if he doesn't get a grip if this
continues
uh in this kind of direction this u-turn
uh hasn't got a grip way it will become
corrosive i would suggest and
and you will hear louder mumblings off
the record certainly to begin with
about whether some stage next year or
whenever the tories should stick with
him as leader
yeah i mean i think if it keeps going
this direction okay you are going to
start having people talking about things
like leadership i i don't think it's
where we are
right now i think what's more likely is
and i think one thing is we haven't
actually had the tories if you think
about it loser you know commons vote in
a big way a commons vote
and i think that actually the brexit uh
you know
shenanigans this week so the government
agreeing with the rebels on an amendment
um lots of reasons for that but i think
there's also a sense that once you rebel
it's quite easy to make that entire
habit and
therefore trying to avoid a mass
rebellion on a single issue is actually
quite
important for number 10 just as a
long-term strategy not just a general
thing because
there's a worry that given that mp's are
in such bad moods already
you could start to create uh regular bad
habits this early on in his premiership
and so i think that's one thing and then
i do wonder if if things do get really
bad you know the polls change
things like that could you see back
benches you know going to number 10 and
making demands
over who he hires in the number 10
operation
i think that kind of thing would happen
before you had
uh you know leadership rivals i think
people at the moment
that has changed a little bit would
still prefer to blame the number 10
operation than boris johnson personally
so that might be where the next trigger
is
james the sense that boris johnson
hasn't got a grip on things
that he's not providing leadership and
direction
that he's here or maybe churchill but
he's certainly not been
chilean prime minister this isn't new
but it's got worse as fraser points out
in the spectator cover story
why can't he get a grip over why is he
not turning this round
why does it just continue to drift and
dither
i think one of the things is that the
kovit your early decision management
segment
shows it's just a very difficult problem
to deal with
and i also think there is a divide in
the prime minister's you know
i mean the prime minister's own soul is
conflicted on this question
you know half of him his natural
instinct would be the person to say come
on everybody
let's get back out there let's go to
work let's keep going
you know that that i think is his
natural libertarian side
on the other hand he is still stunned by
what
by what the first wave wrought uh his
own experience with the virus has
persuaded him that
this isn't just a flu or something like
that and so he
he he is divided on this very question
within himself and that is why i think
the government can sometimes seem
contradictory
and i think you see this in in in this
wrestling match about
christmas you know i think it's quite
clear that if you look at the kind of
opinion about
uh what conditions make the virus spread
that we are very unlikely to have a
traditional
family christmas this year and indeed
politically you would think it would be
better to say it to everyone look i'm
really sorry christmas is probably
cancelled but for this most cavalier of
politicians the idea of being the first
leader since cromwell
to cancel christmas really doesn't
appeal so he keeps trying to suggest
that
something will turn up that will allow
christmas to happen i think politically
probably the more sensible strategy
would be to to under promise and over
deliver
so do all this stuff encourage people to
you know the rule of six all these
restrictions that they had in place and
then hope that you could
pop up on tv at the beginning of advent
and say great news everybody
christmas is back on fraser is
is the bottom line on this that perhaps
mr johnson's abilities and
and knack of getting of doing things was
to
become prime minister he was good at
becoming prime minister
but he's just not that good at being
prime minister fraser
well it's funny that quite often his
allies will say look
you might moan about this that in the
other but look at our opinion poll lead
we're still ahead of labor
look at the majority it's 80. even after
the so-called
rebellion they still passed the northern
ireland withdrawal agreement by
something like um 77 votes a few days
ago
so this this look he is still prime
minister and a few hiccups now a few
embarrassing headlines
aren't going to change the fact that
he's this is a personal victory he won
last december
no other tourney would have won that and
things are fine
but that is a problem if you think like
campaigners i think actually that their
their opinion poll lead can make them a
little bit lazy and thinking that it
actually doesn't matter if you make
these huge mistakes
in parliament but it doesn't matter if
you're not able to lead
a cabinet it's funny that when boris
johnson was london mayor
he he managed it better he had a team of
a large number of deputy mayors
and he'd go and spend a mixture in the
diary he'd have one-to-one time with
them to talk to them
to ask what they wanted to let him know
what he wanted that was his form of
leadership
so people like me this time last year
when i was saying that he'd be a good
prime minister
i was saying look he wouldn't do it
himself but he's got a great ability
to convene brilliant people around him
and inspire them
and abilities to project what he wants
that isn't happening now is cabinet
hardly ever see him it's a mystery to
them
for example what his covet strategy is a
lot of things are a mystery to them
so it's his ability to lead a cabinet
and govern through
a cabinet that is a problem right now
number 10 might be a lot more powerful
than normal but this
bottle of government is visibly buckling
so i think he's going to have to do what
he did
as london mayor he had a very rough
start there then he
got a team around him i think he's going
to have to do a cabinet reshuffle
to appoint cabinet people he really
thinks are up to the job
and then trust them and get back to a
cabinet's government
what we're seeing now is a very
centralized form of government by a
center that simply
isn't up to the job you talk about the
tories opinion paul
lead but isn't that opinion police
getting pretty close to the margin of
error
but it's not that robust elite anymore
oh that's right but still it's strange
at a time where
as katie was saying earlier that there
was a yoga poll out today
showing that they've got the worst um
ratings for handling the pandemic since
the panic
began i don't think any country in
europe
has got worse ratings when you ask
people how do you think your government
has handled the pandemic yet in spite of
all of this
the exams debacle everything else
they're still more popular than the
labour party
now it's a pretty weak strategy to rely
on the weakness of your opponent
right now apart from anything else
britain needs leadership it needs
direction his government
needs direction and simply saying look
we're doing better than labor
is a pretty sorry excuse i think for
giving the leadership which i believe
he's capable of his enemies by the way
think well what do you expect he was
always
a brexiting clown he was no more capable
of handling a pandemic from niger farage
was of conducting a knee operation it
was never going to work
but it's people like me who have been
left most surprised
that our predictions of boris running a
smooth and competent
government have been are beginning to
look now
a little bit naive if the tories of a
leader that can make ed miliband look
good surely they really have a problem
yes they do have a problem and that's
that's contrast we saw a few days ago
between ed miliband giving one of his
better parliamentary performances
and the prime minister is sitting there
looking sad looking berated
looking defeated and some mps who met
him after that
said he looked even worse he just looked
shocked and
just astonished that this had got so out
of control
so the basic skill of a politician is to
try to work out how things are going to
play out
the next week the week after that to see
around corners
he can do that he just hasn't really got
his team together
there's just dysfunctionality and
unforgivable amount
of dysfunctionality in his government i
think he's personally
capable of a lot better and i think it's
we're past time for seeing
just how much better he can be katie if
he does if this continues as drift in
this dither and
an underperforming prime minister
unhappy supporters
uh opinion paul's narrowing if he
if he can't turn this round if it
continues like this
how long before there are really serious
rumblings
in in the tory rank and file
well i think it obviously depends on a
lot of different factors here
um i think one of the things that's
going to be difficult for boris johnson
is usually
and i mean despite the fact you always
say mp should be well rested from the
summer holidays
they really are um they come back a bit
grumpy but you have conference season
and actually so long as the prime
minister doesn't have a cough which
means they can't deliver a speech
it tends to be a fairly unifying moment
for the party getting everyone together
but
we're not going to have that this year
because boris johnson is going to have
to do it remotely
and as good as this zoom call is i don't
think zoom calls can really
galvanize a party to get behind you
again but i think
in terms of timelines for danger points
of boris johnson
we're looking into a very bleak few
months and actually
if you're looking at peak unemployment
factors around a second wave
and i think that if the polling moves i
do think
you know if there's no change i've
spoken to mps today
who some of whom did support boris
johnson saying
we do need to see some light at the end
of the tunnel so i think mps are
mentally prepared to a degree
for a difficult autumn winter i think
that if you get to winter and it's been
even worse than people predicted
but there's still no sign of how you get
to the other side
no sign of how you get to a government
agenda no sign of how you hang out in a
group of above six
then i do think that post uh you know
winter to
spring kind of period could be very
dangerous to boris johnson because
you keep hearing the suggestion that you
know coronavirus which is what has
dominated this so there are other issues
um is something that we have to get to
about march to and then things will
is implied will get much better if
things are still very messy i think in
january february
no site then i think that's gonna be
very difficult for the prime minister
we shall see katie thank you for that
you're watching the week in 60 minutes
coming to you from spectator tv
thanks again to our sponsor then at west
group for supporting
our third broadcast now let's look
across the pond as the election gathers
there
november the third is is election day
for congress and of course the president
and one of the things that we've been
looking at is the trump administration
something of a surprise foreign policy
success
against all the odds whether by design
or accident the president has
managed to reconcile israel with some of
his arab neighbors
the deal with the united arab emirates
and bahrain the aptly named
abraham of course was signed in
washington
this week other arab gulf states are
thought to be ready
to do the same thing mr trump has got
nato members to commit to
more funding uh for defense and nato
projection of force
iran does now seem quite successfully
isolated
and mr trump did get away with what was
a risky assassination
of the iranian general qasim suleimani
do you remember him
nope i've forgotten to but trump's
critics are not impressed a group of
foreign policy manager and stateside
have recently condemned his policy as
gravely damaging to the united states
pointing to mr trump's cozy relations
with strong men
dictators from mr putin and the kremlin
to mr zee
in beijing his dismissal of nato again
and again
and of course his somewhat undiplomatic
tweeting
so are they right let's talk to devin
crosh he's a foreign policy expert
who served for eight years on the pink
pentagon's defense policy board
about how we should evaluate trump's
foreign policy record devin because
are you surprised that mr trump now
actually has a foreign policy record
i have to say i am andrew i i had no
expectations
coming in that that this was an area
that concerned him at all
the allegations of isolationism you know
made sense from what i saw in the
campaign
um as you point out it's it's
it's all very it's a little bit like
black boris it's a little opaque as to
how he's come up with
with the foreign policies that he
actually has executed
um they do veer sharply from you know
the received wisdom
on arms control treaties and you know
as i pointed out in my piece the moving
of the embassy
in israel to jerusalem this was
decades-long
convictions that he has sort of you know
coming in i mean i suppose one could say
coming in fresh he is questioned and and
reasonably so
um but i i was it was certainly not my
my expectation that any such thing would
emerge
i mean one of the criticisms of the
middle east deal that was done this week
is that of course it leaves the
palestinians hung out to dry
uh they're not part of of this
and you sometimes wonder if mr trump
cares but the fact is the sunni arab
states are fed up with the palestinians
too they
have decided after dealing for decades
with the palestinian leadership they've
basically turned on the palestinian
leadership and they
because they're terrified of iran and
israel sees iran as its biggest enemy as
well
they've decided it's more important i
would suggest to make common
cause with israel than it is to do
something for the palestinians and mr
trump's got along with that
well i also think frankly that it was um
trump's pointing out that the arab
street
has largely been bypassed by the arab
states there is there has not been a
concern about palestinians for many many
years amongst the arab states
there was just this tacit you know
notion understanding amongst amer
you know the west that this would cause
you know blood in the streets
they've despaired of of the palestinian
state i don't know that they've
turned as much as they've despaired
there has been zero
effort on the part of the palestinian
state to accommodate any of the very
uh accommodating um
offers that were made so most
importantly i think
this administration has made it clear
that iran
is a strategic threat to
us all and that they would actually move
to contain this
that is compelled i believe the gulf
states to actually believe
that this made sense to to come
alongside america and
israel uh at this point my fear frankly
andrew is that foreign policy is very
much the domain of the president in
america it's not it's not something
terribly widely shared
much of this can be overturned and
really very quickly
um an effort to re-upholster the
iran agreement could be forthcoming in a
matter of months
and i think that would shift many of
these dynamics uh quite profoundly
i mean the europeans feel a bit left out
because they're still carrying the
palestinian flag
and they weren't involved in this deal
and i think many uh of
european governments were slow to see
this new dynamic in the middle east
which
right you have to give the trump
administration
some credit for it did see it and it
capitalized
on it but the other european concern
in this notice of european concern about
mr trump when it comes to foreign policy
is that he seems of this ability to cozy
up
to dictators whether it's president z or
president putin or
even in north korea and he's quite
cavalier with his democratic allies like
angela merkel
or president macron that that causes
concern
i really find this this allegation of
him cozying up
you know pretty questionable i mean he's
gone after china in a way that
no other administration has ever gone
after china he's
he is goring ox is a very prominent
republicans in so doing
um and in the case of putin i mean
there really there was zero that came
out of the long and tedious
mueller investigation in this recent
kosovo agreement he's taking on uh
russia in a pretty profound way by
luring in the serbs on this one
um i you know i i think
there is a certain admiration in his
mind of people who keep order within
their country
this is this is problematic but
i'm just not sure that cozying up has
been demonstrated in policy
it's certainly true that he took a tough
line uh against russia the british
government's
uh bequest and behest after the uh
the the poisoned attack
in uh salisbury and you know he expelled
a a lot of
russians foreign policy i would suggest
will not pay
play a huge part in this election though
anti-chinese sentiment particularly with
covert will will be there but
even if people don't follow these things
very closely
the idea of israel and arabs say sitting
down
not having peace not attacking each
other anymore
that kind of resonates i would suggest
with the mary with the american people
you know you're right foreign policy is
never featured in these elections and
frankly i'm not sure
it will by any means uh in this
that is in no small part the far the
fault of this administration which has
accomplished things that are
you know indeed significant and doesn't
seem to be talking about them at all
and that's true on domestic policy as
well if you consider our respective
domestic economies pre-covered you know
unemployment had never been lower et
cetera so
there's there comes some missing
narratives here but um
i hope the visuals of this do impress
americans because it's unprecedented
but i don't hold out um
great hope that there will be much
reference made to this
i fear biden did make a statement
yesterday i believe that
you know these agreements are you know
nothing significant that that trump's
policy on iran
had been a boon to iran and a bust
to the u.s and i kind of found that
beggared belief a little bit
that might be news to tehran exactly
if mr biden was to occupy the white
house
would there be i mean a lot of people
think well that'd be more return to
normality
uh whatever normality was it'd be more
emphasizing nato
the atlantic alliance being friendly
again with the europeans and all the
rest of it
would there be much difference of an
abide in foreign policy
well there was some talk this week that
biden's china policy wouldn't be
terribly different from
trump's and they and the reality is that
trump's
got a bipartisan backing in the congress
that is
you know totally uncharacteristic of the
rest of his
his policy making but
there is there is growing support in
america for his his
and i suspect even biden would go along
with that there's a
the the big difference if if you were to
you know look down the road i think
would be rejoining the iran agreement
which i think
biden intends to do i don't think there
would be
um much attention paid to the european
allies i just think there's
there's you know not so much
interaction at the significant
policy levels that will be
dominating in any way shape or form the
european union really is not
making big moves and big gestures that
that will engage americans
but uh i think on on
china there will be a major once again a
reset
that will be getting to yes and and
whatever it takes to
to keep the chinese happy investing in
the u.s economy and vice versa
right interesting okay let's uh move on
to some questions uh
from our audience uh alex points out uh
after our
somewhat uh aborted uh interview with
anders tegel on a train
in uh in sweden that there are no masks
on swedish trains in fact
there are no masks in sweden alex
it has been swedish government policy
not to ask people to wear
masks they don't think they do much good
if you want to wear one i'm sure you can
in stockholm or wherever else
but it's not policy and in the streets
of sweden
you don't see people walking around
wearing masks
carol ford asks sweden still has covered
measures in place
that's true carol or are they and is
there success based on greater
compliance
i'll uh come to fraser to that but the
they've had a measuring
place that although they've not had a
lockdown there was a limit on no more
than 50 people could gather in any
uh one area the schools uh were there
but not over 16.
all the schools are now back in the
universities too so there
it wasn't a lot done and i think in
restaurants and bars you couldn't
sit at the bar you had to sit at a table
preferably outside for a while
so fraser there wasn't a lockdown as
we had it or most of uh europe had it
but there were rules in place there were
rules
not very many but the big difference was
that sweden had what they called a
voluntary lockdown a soft
lockdown where the government asked
people to take care
and they did if you actually look at the
figures i mean
pretty much all my swedish friends for
example have been working for home for a
long time
and just as we were uh when you go out
to the
the street center you see far fewer
people there
and their transport went down a lot and
when it was the may bank holiday weekend
i think
the amount of transport was something
like 20 of what it was
normally the year before so swedes did
take huge numbers of precautions
they did way more than the government
asked but the sweden's government's
point
was this is how you do it you don't have
covert marshals you don't
have police to break up groups of
children playing in the park
if you ask people to take care and be
responsible
they will be responsive to that now that
leads to a big question could britain
have behaved that way
and i disagree with the consensus that
you so often hear that brits are
basically drunken louts who would never
um listen to what the government advised
that it wasn't for the police
we would never have locked down i think
that we would have behaved pretty much
as the swedes behaved so yeah there are
a few restrictions not very many the
rule of 50
is about to be lifted to the rule of 500
as
of october but sweden did lock down and
is still
a country which is moving about far less
than it did before the pandemic
indeed i see some someone has written to
tell us that um
yesterday they were limiting people with
the number who could go in
uh to shops and restaurants so there
were some
controls in place with nothing like a
lockdown cell roberts is an interesting
question here james
uh if in a few weeks reported cases do
not translate
into increased hospitalizations and
death rates
because at the moment the cases are
rising but hospitalization and death
rates have not
uh they've risen but from a very small
base
do you think the government will relax
or will it be taken as evidence
that the lockdown works how will that
play james i i think this is a
fascinating question if you look at the
at the moment the viewing government is
that we are kind of tracking
france and spain you look what's
happening in spain the spanish
government have taken measures
i think they introduced a rule of ten
rather than the uk's rule of six
but the cases in spain are going down
again and
you haven't you have seen obviously more
hospitalizations than death but you
haven't seen
anything like the spike you saw in the
first wave
and so i think this is the big question
i mean one of the very unpredictable
things
is what is happening with this virus and
i think
i personally think that every single
issue in british politics is going to
come to be seen through the prism of the
pandemic
for example i think what happens on
brexit well a lot of that will depend
on what is happening with covid you know
if
uh the case numbers continues to rise
and that leads as
people in government think it will to
increase authorizations and increase
deaths
are you really thinking that a month
from now the european accounts on
october 15th
the uk government is as is notionally
its policy at the moment it's going to
say well if there isn't a deal by then
we're going to tell everyone in the
country to start preparing for no deal
i personally doubt the the politics of
that
because that would play right in the kia
starman's house kirsten wants to say
just you said you told us brexit was
done get on with fighting this pandemic
and i think it would be quite hard to
explain to people in that
moment why you are now choosing to
to have this massive brexit rap but if
as you say
you know this doesn't translate into
great hospitalizations and deaths and
and we are kind of essentially out the
other end of this by october 15th
the political moon might be very
different so i think this is the big
question which is
what happens but i but i think the
interesting thing is there is absolutely
no doubt that
although in government they have no
desire to do a second national lockdown
they are completely convinced that these
local lockdowns
are effective in slowing the spread of
the virus now
i i think as as fraser and casey were
saying earlier the danger is
that you that you you you essentially
get to a national lockdown
but just gradually if you look at the
number of places in the uk that have
been locked down
yeah and obviously the big enchilada
here is london you know we know from
elite government documents so the
government's view is
that if cases begin to rise in london
there is so much
travel within the city but you couldn't
say we'll lock down
west london but we'll leave the rest of
the city to carry on as wars
and i think that is the question which
is you know at the moment the uk aim is
to have local lockdowns we don't have
local lockdowns we have regional
lockdowns
and you know once if you're in a
situation where you've got six or seven
regional knockdowns covering
three of the biggest cities in the
country that's not that different from a
national lockdown
well you mentioned europe james anthony
linden writes
how confident is the panel that a trade
deal with the eu
will be agreed by the end of the year
there you go let's put you all on the
spot katie
we tried to press james on percentages
on a recent episode of our coffeehouse
shots podcast
and he suggested he he wasn't very
tempted but he gave us a very wide
margin
and i personally think it's around 40
but i think anyone who tells you they
know what's happening is lying
in terms of the exact details i realize
it's a guess
but you think more of a chance of no
deal then than deal
i think that you can look at what's
happened this week in terms
of uh the drama around the internal
market bill and actually see it as
a political tactic a bit like the drama
number 10 created before they came up
with a deal last time
but i think there are still some quite
outstanding issues and difficulties so
i would say 40 to 50 but that's a wimp
so i'm gonna say uh
less likely than not all right fraser
and i would say
70 chance i'm more optimistic of a deal
of a deal yes and not because i'm
optimistic about it here right now but
when it comes down to it
it's a no-brainer for both sides the eu
needs
and free or trade of us we need it with
them why would either of us make life
difficult for each other
at the end we went through this last
time all of this drama it has it
has to look for all the world as if it's
all going to collapse and there's not
going to be a deal
and only at that moment will you get a
deal that simply is the choreography of
it
so i don't think we can read too much
into the failure of
talks right now um in a way you have to
go through this
in the dark the night has to be at his
darkest point before you get to the dawn
james i i think the chance of a deal are
rising
i i think they were very bad a few weeks
ago and i mean they are on
an uptick and i think that is partly
because
there is there is an odd situation at
the moment where the public rhetoric is
blood and thunder on both sides yet
i'm very struck by talking to those on
the uk negotiating team
that uh the last round of talks in
london which were in the middle of this
round
were they said now this is admittedly
from a low bar were actually more
constructive than previous rounds
and i noticed that but it was
interesting
but what if it was very striking there
was a fascinating reuters report this
week
where the eu side are essentially saying
the same so they actually made some
proper progress on fish one of the
sticking points
uh in the in those negotiations in
london so i think you have to learn to
kind of disinter
the kind of brexit theater from the
minutiae of the negotiations
i still think the big question is you
know do you get that political
will and engagement to push this thing
over the line
and that is that that is the big
question here i think that you know do
does boris johnson start engaging with
european counterparts
do they start saying right come on we
can fix these issues
because i think ultimately with a bit of
political will and creativity
they are fixable and and i think the
other crucial issue is whether both
sides are prepared to look at the
current situation with covid
and decide that actually it would be
better to
come to an agreement now and then have
various fights over the next few years
rather than concertinating them into
this period
here's a question from peter fleet given
nancy pelosi that's the speaker of the
house and congress
and joe biden's comments this week on a
uk us
trade deal is it now clear that donald
trump's re-election
is in the uk's national interest devon
oh you're muted you have to unmute got
it
sorry about that that's all right um i'd
have to agree
i think there's uh you know there's a
desire to sabotage
um on the part of both those parties
named
and i you know the
the underlying sentiment of brexit
appalled the
the democrat elite so it wouldn't
surprise me
in the slightest if that's in fact the
case
peter richardson wants to know from you
one of the chances that mr trump
could surprise the polls and win
oh lord i'm the world's worst predictor
of these things
uh i do think polls have proved
themselves to be
um you know unreliable in in
many many many instances and this one is
not
wouldn't surprise me if that's in fact
the case there is however
you just can't underestimate the furvid
the degree to which the media social
media the blanket
rhetoric is anti-trump so i i have just
no way of
of scoping uh devon gets the blame
for the urban unrest that we've seen
going on all through the summer it's
surprised me how long it's lasted uh the
number of nights in seattle and portland
and so on that
town in in wisconsin who gets the blame
is it in the end the president because
ultimately he is
in charge of law and order and previous
presidents
when faced with riots have been at the
forefront
to deal with the rise or is it the the
often quite left-wing democratic mayors
in charge of these towns who's getting
the wrap
i don't well who's getting the rap is a
separate question from who's responsible
it's it's an astonishing organization
that keeps the portland
rioting going uh whatever it is 100 plus
plus days there's a there's a there's a
you know a host of questions surrounding
how and
and uh you know sources
resources of these organized efforts but
we have a federal system in this country
and everybody complains that donald
trump hasn't you know had federal laws
on covet i think that's kind of
far-fetched in the sense that it's a
very different population
and a very different set of challenges
we you
are facing extreme polarities
in governments in various states
you know the texans would would have a
very different response to this
than would uh you know illinois
and their donald trump has offered
national guard
when the governor's turned that down or
it's really not a
you know it's it's got to be up to them
let's come back to uh blighty and uh
here's a good question
james from alexander government is
dominic cummings the reason
boris johnson is doing so badly
i think it's an interesting question
which is the dominant comments from
boris johnson
that they are they have complementary
skills
you know dominic cummings is is not a
front of house person
but he is a details person in in the way
that boris johnson
is not well it was an interesting moment
when uh earlier in the clover crisis
people kept saying
oh prime minister do you read the
details of the scientific papers
and boris johnson essential answer was
no
and i think the point about is he's not
reading that because
that is one of the things that dominate
cummings does for him i mean
i think the interesting question about
them both is that they have this shared
belief about
reforming and changing the british state
in quite dramatic ways kind of rewiring
whitehall
the the the the big question name is you
know how fast can you do that
and i think one of the big questions
about the the being prepared to leave
the eu at a trade deal is
looking at the state's response to covid
are you
confident that this british minister of
state could deal with all the challenges
that would be thrown up
by leaving the eu without a trade deal
what i don't understand though james is
dominic cummings is meant to be the
strategic
genius he's also meant to be
the man who has most of the prime
minister's
ear you know they go back a long way
mr johnson has expended a lot of
political capital
on keeping dominic cummings in 10
downing street so if if these things are
true
why is the government ricocheting all
over the place welcome to the strategic
genius
because i think number 10 is is
stretched too thin
i think number 10 has taken on a huge
amount to itself
and i think that makes it very difficult
to deal with this
this remarkable challenge of kovitch you
know this week dominic cummings was
photographed
uh holding a letter based on the 1980s
defense review in the us which was a
reminder of how much time
he is spending on this integrated review
into foreign policy and defense
but obviously if he's doing that that
means that you can't be doing
the day-to-day stuff on covet i think
this is one of the challenges
this government uh has
i i cannot think of another government
in living memory
that has such a set of ambitious agendas
it wants to
to change almost everything and i think
the point is
if you're going to do that i think you
need to be prepared to delegate more
to your capital ministers you need
cabinet ministers with their own agendas
who are saying right
i believe in this reform let me run with
that
and i think the problem number 10 of god
is you know they would have
even without clovis they would be they
would they would have taken an
awful lot onto their own plate with
kobit they have got
we've got an amount of stuff to deal
with but that i'm not sure it is humanly
possible to do
uh um
is why does dominic cummings
not have more influence
in writing the ship if he's so pivotal
to the government
well i think as james touches on there's
an issue in terms of
numbers um and i think dominic cummings
also has his pet projects so he has
things that he is the most interested in
i get the sense that when it comes to
coronavirus well
it's quite clear no one in number 10
came into government thinking i want to
guide the prime minister for your public
health crisis
and it's something they are having to
live with but it's not their passion
about anyone there
and i think they've got an issue in the
sense that because this is a really
tight-knit number 10
they trust very few people a lot of the
people who are in there
either come from city hall days but i
would say a higher number
come from the vote leave e-referendum
campaign so
even if you say you don't trust cabinet
ministers if you have a you know a view
that
elective members of parliament don't
have sufficient skills that you need
which is a view i think some of them
hold i think they also struggle to even
add more aids to the group
and that's an issue and just looking at
i suppose the original question about
whether dominant cummings makes boris
johnson's problem
you know harder adds to it i think
amongst
tory mps dominic cummings does make
boris johnson's life a bit more
difficult
particularly since barnard castle but
before that
i think as part of the issue dominic
cummings and lots of the vote leave team
are not particularly pro-mps there's
comments that we can look at which
they've made before they entered you
know dining street
and that does have an issue and i think
it does
add to this sense when mps feel a bit
unloved
it adds to the sense of number 10 not
only doesn't really have time for them
but doesn't really respect them
and i think we got a sense of that this
week when charles walker
in the brexit debate stood in the
chamber and ultimately said
you know if you treat us like dogs we'll
start to bite back
and i think that is part leads to the
whole number 10 operation
now just finally number 10 clearly have
made the calculation
that it is worth that to have dominic
cummings in there because they think
that he is
important enough in terms of strategy so
that's their calculation but it does
make parliamentary relations more tricky
razor final question to you is is the
government still planning to break the
law
or is that another u-turn has that now
been quietly shelved as well
well they've tried to fudge the issues
saying that if they do
require another vote of parliament i
tell you where they got into a mess here
they thought this was about breaking in
there's no such thing as international
law under the british system there is no
what the queen in parliament what she
decides is law
so technically they are correct but it
didn't work out the problem was
wasn't so much breaking the law is
breaking their word now britain is about
to hopefully do a lot of
trade deals with a lot of countries
these countries need to know
that a british promise is kept and also
one of the reasons that boris johnson
is sticking to his um pledges for
hospitals for police numbers for
nurse numbers etc is because he wants to
be seen as a man
who keeps his promise he hadn't quite
worked out this threatening to break
international law
also means saying you won't care about
keeping your promises
or not so right now they're trying to
fudge it and i think he will end this
week thinking a lot
more carefully about shocking attack six
used against the eu
because they might just backfire on him
i think this also illustrates that
something about the about the cabinet
jeffrey cox was kind of pushed out as
attorney general in that first reshuffle
because it was kind of felt that he
asked too many questions raised too many
issues
when actually this whole debacle
illustrates why you want an attorney
general who pushes back to ask questions
because
i think if they had had jeffrey cox as
attorney general they would have found a
way to kind of freshen much of what they
wanted to do
but they would have found a way to do it
that didn't involve
than saying what brandon lewis had to
say in the house of commons and which
sparked off
both a parliamentary rebellion and
international repercussions i think if
they'd been prepared
to have a cabinet that would would
challenge more they'd have got to a
better place on this issue okay we'll
leave it there for
this week apologies to our viewers the
our anders tegel
interview uh didn't quite work out as
planned he was such an important guest
to get
the man who's been the architect of this
almost unique swedish response to covid
we thought our heart sank when we
learned he was actually going to be on a
train
apparently he commutes an hour each way
and back every day but we thought it
worth trying it
we assumed that uh swedish 4g would be
much better than british 4g but it
turned out it was just as useless as our
4g
anyway thanks for joining the week in 60
minutes we'd love to find out what you
thought of it and how we could improve
it obviously don't do interviews and
trains
you don't need to tell us about that but
send your thoughts to spectator tv
at spectator dot co dot uk thanks to the
home team as always a very special
thanks
to devon cross great to see you thank
you for being part of our show tonight
uh devon and again thanks for our
supportive sponsors
nat west group now you can watch again
recommend the show to your friends it'll
shortly be ready for viewing on the
spectator website
and on the spectators youtube channel we
hope you'll join us again next thursday
at 6 pm london time
until then bye bye
[Music]
you